there's this great picture of you I
wanted to show briefly when I'm tempted
but it was a paparazzi photo and I don't
know what happened to you are you on
your way to murder someone or have you
just murdered someone there's these are
face masks because like when you do
stuff like a facial but here's the deal
why did he jump in a car and flee the
night before this happened was my
birthday yeah and I got a call from Chan
who was who's filming herbs doing the
cover of Vanity Fair and Annie Leibowitz
was was shooting in he was like Annie
wants to film and wants to do it like
come over we're gonna have a photo shoot
one of the great photographers in the
world you do that oh my god so I took
Everly I put her in the car she naps so
washing that I drove round LA with the
mask on to try and make myself look a
little bit less hungover
but I really worked beautifully because
that was you were the mask of us for a
second I to me without makeup you know
it's so bad but it's I was like I needed
every little bit I could get I love it
I'm sure it worked out fine
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please